here in Sauvignon at least one resident
looks at to have a good year polum
people a runs a winery about 200
kilometers south of Paris it was founded
by his great-grandfather despite the
economic crisis in France Pele can still
sell his wines at a good price
he exports nearly half of them wine
embodies the character of our village
and our soil that's also why we were
awarded the AOC certification which
confirms that we offer a regional
products our Sauvignon can't just be
copied and produced in another location
or in a low-wage country the soil is
completely different there and trying to
mass produce our wine would strip it of
its magic wine is one of France's
leading exports and French vintners rely
on access to the single European market
but some see things differently like
jeonghoon a coup a
he's campaigning for the far-right
National Front headed by Martine lepen
who hopes to win the upcoming
presidential election she's calling for
protectionism saying it will give
Frances economy a boost
we have many farmers here and about 30%
of them will probably be forced to go
out of business soon due to unfair
competition we need intelligent
protectionism
we must finally impose tariffs on
products that are imported to France and
sold at dumping prices because they're
produced elsewhere in Europe at very low
costs without maintaining social or
environmental standards it's an argument
that many rural residents agree with
especially young people labourers and
people who are out of work some opinion
polls put the National Front in the lead
right now
Mahwah Bugatti log Europe means open
borders they need to be closed it might
not be easy to leave the EU but we need
to close the borders that's the only way
to protect our country leaving the euro
would probably hurt at first and make a
lot of people very angry
it could even lead to a civil war but
something has to be done and that
includes returning to the franc for Pele
leaving the euro
never mind the EU is unthinkable
illusions what shocks me the most is
that so many young people vote for the
National Front I just don't understand
what they see in the party I would never
cast my vote for it
kuai II and his fellow campaigners say
the reason is clear unemployment in
France is about 10 percent only the
National Front they say will protect the
remaining French jobs from immigrants
but not everyone here agrees you have no
right to be here
get lost you know perfectly well that
we're allowed to campaign here
you idiot idiot a fascist is and remains
a fascist you're too young to have seen
what happened back then my damla pen
should be ashamed
we aren't fascists we just want to take
back control of our country so is there
anything to the claim that France is
under the EU thumb winegrower police has
many French farmers only survived thanks
to hefty subsidies from Brussels closing
the borders anachronistic it's absurd
today we can't just curl up into a
little ball here and isolate ourselves
like a tiny Gallic the world is what it
is and we have to learn to deal with
that if France imposes import tariffs
other countries will too
then our exports would drop which would
hurt everyone here
parlez won't reveal who will get his
vote on April 23rd but it will be a
candidate who supports free trade he
says it's the only way that his
sauvignon can continue to be enjoyed all
over the world